what people want to know about how do
you make a marriage work I say marriages
is a work of art and it's half art and
it's half work it it literally does take
work great marriages are not accidental
they are intentional and it takes work I
don't believe in the phrase
incompatibility I honestly believe that
any two people can be compatible if you
grow up the bottom line is I want what I
want you want what you wanted that's
just selfishness and the purpose of
marriage is to teach you to grow up it's
to teach you to be unselfish we all
think marriage is to meet all my needs
well first place there are many needs
you have in your life that your husband
or your wife will never be able to meet
and so you're setting yourself for a
major disappointment if you think you're
ever gonna find the man a woman is gonna
meet all your needs they won't only God
can meet all your needs and a lot of
people getting married
looking in their husband or wife to
fulfill the need that only God can
fulfill and that just causes
disappointment frustration bitterness
and anger as a pastor now for over 30
years I've counseled many many couples
through marriage problems and in
premarital counseling all marriage
problems come down to 105 areas money
sex in-laws communication and children
when Kay and I got married we went five
for five in the first month and if our
marriage was down dooby-doo down down
and we didn't we were in love
but we did not get along because we're
the exact opposite in every single DNA
cell of our of our bodies I say hi she
says lo I say why she says I don't know
it's so blood do blood we are literally
totally opposite each other but that's
not that can be a good thing if you're
willing to grow I've grown more from my
wife than from any other person she's
grown more from me than from any other
person because if you have the same
strengths then you tend to have the same
weaknesses so you both get depressed at
the same time
you both get up at the same time and
marriage is complementary it's not
competition
it's not 50/50 it's 100% 100% it's
learning to offer yourself to the other
person and they offer themselves to you
and it's not well I'll go this far if
you go this far it's it's 100 100
percent it's learning to really to be
unselfish and so I believe that there
are things you can only learn in
marriage if you don't get married you
need to get in some other kind of close
relationship where you have to give
yourself away and I strongly believe in
taking care of you know nieces and
nephews and helping with kids and things
like that if marriage teaches young self
is just having a kid really teaches
young sellers because all of a sudden
you can't just live on your own schedule
you have to say well what you know think
of somebody else first
it's work but it's worth it